and exert turn on the lights
you gotta love America I mean we love
America go say yes and I'm not just
referring to their incredible house
automation systems oh no it's it's the
mere fact that the United States of
America has electricity that excites us
you see we don't have electricity in
South Africa but jokes aside there is
something at the moment in South Africa
called load shedding there's rolling
blackouts throughout South Africa yeah
do some research check it out but unto a
lighter note you see you're a little bit
and on a lighter note happy new year
happy 2020 and because this is my first
video of the year I would like to say a
couple of things first a couple of years
ago I made the jump from being a
traditional film director to moving over
to YouTube thinking it's been an
incredible ride but I'm not gonna bore
you with all that
as you know consistency is probably the
most important part of YouTube and I
have been really [ __ ] that's been
consistent I really struggle with it I
guess I've just been trying to make
films that are too crafted to perfectly
perfect and over the last few months
have been spending a lot of time
thinking about where I want to be what I
want to do you know what do you want to
become when you older kind of thing even
though I'm I'm old I'm getting old and
the answer that always come back to you
is I want to make incredible foams I
want to make great phones so so here I
find myself in Los Angeles the place to
make a movie a big movie feature-length
phone that's my goal over the next year
along with that and possibly even more
important is I am going to be consistent
on YouTube
said that before said that before said
that before a lot of times this time
you'll see two videos a week to to make
the best big phone possible I need to
research by research I mean going
through everything that's been created
from the shittest [ __ ] to the greatest
great and that ladies and gentlemen is
my new show
it's called scene review where I review
scenes based on a theme along with the
guests every week and then together we
will recreate one of these scenes and
I'll show you how I do it let's invite
this week's guest the incredible the
humble the sweet charming beautiful
fantastic excellent be great my fiancee
Gabby s Daisy
[Music]
welcome firstly the burning question
what happened to your arm
I try to snowboard snowboard again
snowboarding moving on to lighter things
Gabby and I are getting married soon and
I don't know if you know this but a
wedding is an extremely stressful
process for the bride I care about the
wedding I really want to have input but
I just don't want to say the wrong thing
I just I'm terrified I was gonna say you
could be [ __ ] crazy sometimes and
here's a piece of advice for all you
lovebirds out there planning on you know
getting the old ball-and-chain one day
see how long have you been planning this
wedding about it yet yeah okay
so take it from us I mean take it from
me the best possible thing you can do as
a groom is to agree you agree
I agree with the winning things hanging
off the roof
what I like those things I like those
things I do I do and in the spirit of
ensuring that our wedding is just
perfect
I've selected this week's seats which
range from cringed to awesome across the
spectrum from online videos to movies
are you ready this is the what can go
wrong in South Africa
wait wait wait
I am deeply concerned by how amuse gab
says by this when I asked gabs his dad
if I could take her hand in marriage he
said do you not want to be happy okay
[Music]
which is is a joke I'm I'm guessing yeah
anyways this scene reminded me of that
hey I just want to thank you guys one
last time for being here it's the best
day ever
don't even start with me Franklin okay
you need to walk away from this ASAP
what you need to get out Frankie like to
see what's in your dad going updates to
me exactly you can still bail yeah come
on this is the best thing that's ever
happened to me
why'd you give that six months y'all
think that's gonna change I had a wife
kids first I'm like a happy guy to you
Frankie I think this is something cool
to do right now is say let's relook at
our marriage in ten years time from this
date and see if we've become like boring
old people that don't like each other
yes you say it as if like marriage is
the killer but I didn't say that no no
it's like the general like whether you
marry it or you're not married if you
with someone and you're putting in the
same work that you put in the beginning
you'll have the same the success
throughout
gabs and i have a sausage dog named Joe
[Music]
who is what did you call him we do
everything with Joey and Joey was there
when I proposed
he brought the ring in and for the
actual wedding ceremony we can get him
to walk down the aisle but he is not
trained
[Music]
thank you
twelve and a half years mate for that
can't teach an old man new tricks can't
teach an old dog new tricks isn't the
thing that you can you can in the
spirits of being positive for joking you
can teach an old dog new tricks I chose
this scene because this is you and I
[Music]
that's be competitive but our wedding is
gonna be way better absolutely
this was pretty but I was very cold okay
right yeah I was chilly the whole time
like every time after we leave a wedding
me like your ass [ __ ] too long liking
you and they're a tough crowd you know
like this was under awesome weddings
over like that amazing first dance but I
find this cream if it was something like
really bad editing you know for me I put
the video together I think that they
could have not used his voice sounds of
auto-tune
let me fix it quickly you making my
dreams come true
[Music]
this is like a cringe compilation but in
my mind I think that these people are
awesome the waiting is if you take a
quick glance at the venue yeah and the
fact that people are wearing a nice got
a lipid the dad is like a yeah I mean
fair enough yeah there's something
sincere
Oh cute that's what I'm saying that is
so cute I did I chose friends because
Joey our sausage dog is named after Joey
and friends the Ross if you Delta V I
Ross I Ross
take the Emily take the Rachel to take
the emerg that is the words here I think
that that is like the ultimate I've
never met I've never ever thought about
saying the wrong name well yeah whose
name are you gonna mention let's move on
from that run jobs and I've known each
other for what 15 years her older
brother nick has been a best friend of
mine for that entire duration of time so
I have been in this scenario and my hope
in my mind was saying you were also
doing this but we were just unaware of
[Music]
so they're not doing updating no that's
you and I
[Music]
but I I thought that you didn't like me
back then I thought you didn't like me
back then hey now we've reached the part
of the show we're gonna recreate one of
the scenes our favorite scene was the
last scene because well I found out that
gabs actually didn't like me back then
but I I in fact lighter but we're gonna
recreate that in my mind okay and I'm
gonna show you how it's done
to recreate the scene I would need beige
the dramas from Target tripods a ladder
cable ties duct tape a slider cameras
and my friend Jonah
who with a wig and a lot of imagination
it looks kind of similar to Owen well
somehow I wrote a really basic shot list
then set up my cheap shitty rig what I
can imagine the electronic rig in the
first shot looked like as they moved on
and shift with a two or three axis
gimbal we just don't have time for that
[Music]
that's around
hmm good question if I didn't there's
always story blogs the amazing sponsor
of today's video we never have needed a
quick b-roll clip templates or graphic
after calling wrap story blocks is where
I go I know that I can always count on
them and if you have the same needs you
can too and with a library already over
1 million acids strung they have
everything and they're constantly making
updates which is also click on the link
in the description to learn more about
story blocks and make your videos a
little easier and that much better now
the moment you've all been waiting for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you